if you look at all the polling of gen Z
you know baby boomers when you talk
about patriotism in this country and
being proud to be American baby boomers
are at 70 something percent then you
have Gen X right uh at I think 50
Millennials and 40 and then gen Z 16
proud to be American yeah and you see
the stats that we discussed yesterday
from The Wall Street Journal about
having children and work and work ethic
and patriotism and the numbers are
plummeting and you know a lot of large
contingency of our audience are 20 and
30 year olds in this Millennial gen Z
generation how do we improve upon this
and get this back of get patriotism back
to being uh exactly right there Mainstay
in America right there 16 of gen Z are
proud to be Americans Where Do We Go
From Here well it's very simple adults
have to be adults again
uh my mom and daddy were the adults in
the house and when my dad sat me down at
the age of 15 on the steps of his home
651 Kennesaw Avenue Northeast Atlanta
Georgia
30308-404-874-2836 he told me at the age
of 15 that there's no greater honor than
to wear the uniform in the United States
of America now this is a man that was
born in the south in 1920.
and that's what he felt this was a man
that went and fought for his country in
World War II when this country did not
recognize him as being equal to others
but that's what he told me and he
challenged me to be the first officer in
the family because he said I want you to
be better and more than what I was how
old were you at the time 15 and so what
did I start off with I started out in
High School Junior ROTC Grady High
School Atlanta Georgia and then I went
on to University of Tennessee on 31 July
1982 the only time I ever saw my dad
with tears in his eyes the day that he
penned on second Lieutenant bars it's
amazing but see that's what is not
happening it was not happening is that
parents are not taking charge in their
homes parents are Outsourcing their kids
to these teachers and and everyone else
until the culture as well my parents
were it they were the end State I did
not come home from the University of
Tennessee for Thanksgiving Christmas or
any type of break and say my my
professor is smarter than you if that
had been the case I wouldn't be sitting
here
so what happened when all of a sudden
you know Proverbs 22 6 says train up a
child the way they should go so when
they grow old they shut up depart from
it when did we all of a sudden in our
home say we're not going to raise our
kids because that's what the lab
believes
your kids are not yours when Terry
McCall stood there on that debate stage
in Virginia doing the gubernatorial
election and said parents do not have a
right in what their children are being
taught
that's what they believe that's what
they have been saying in their own
little private meetings now what is it
well we're going to tell your kid that
if his little boy maybe he's a little
girl and we're not going to let you know
parents so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]